[Music]
it's the call of the singing lemur
recorded and played out on the phone
he's holding
the injuries are the only mammal besides
humans who use patterned rhythm it's
their way of communicating
[Music]
within seconds there's a cacophony in
response to the recording from the
lemurs all above us in the rainforest
the guides are monitoring the lima
numbers the singing primates are on the
verge of extinction in the wild
threatened by hunting and habitat loss
exacerbated by climate change that call
had an amazing effect they're actually
actually replying
[Applause]
[Music]
very noisy
too much i make this image fall right
he's calling it reasons what this is
after fighting oh [ __ ]
yes
very special yes until 810 kilometers
you can ensuring his communication like
that
kristen is head of the guardians of this
forest the protectors of the enormously
rich natural treasures living here and
only found here but they are very few in
number
and look at the scale of this forest
they're trekking through this is a
relatively small one just 750 hectares
but underneath the canopy there is
wildlife plants and insects you'll find
nowhere else on earth
but the deforestation is happening at
such a rate that studies suggest all of
these eastern forests could disappear
within 50 years and with them the unique
treasures in them
people collect beliefs to export i don't
know for what what kind of essential
oils
but until now that is a big problem
in a world forest here
and we make a patrol like this to to
interrupt and to stop completely hundred
percent
the lemurs survive on these trees if
these trees disappear the lemurs
disappear
and you can only find these lemurs and
there are over 100 different species of
them here in madagascar in the wild and
they are the most endangered
mammals
in the world at the moment
they're trying to grow new trees endemic
to this area but these are small
beginnings and it takes time they don't
have with extreme weather hampering
those efforts
normally this is the one of the rain
seasons but no
there's no rain this is uh i can say
this is the problem with the climate
change
they call it slash and burn almost half
of this forest has been left degraded
due to this practice clearing land for
crops and it has a devastating impact
among those killed almost to the point
of extinction is the golden mantella
frog
all the country's frogs and they have
more than 300 different species play a
vital role
if there is a place without frog
there must be
a big problems of malaria
because frog eat insect date mostly
mosquitoes and ants
so if if if places have not any frog
they must have a big problems of some
disease
but the forest guardians have their work
cut out for them
making notes and taking gps locations of
fell trees isn't halting the destruction
and the locals pounce when they know the
patrols are off duty it is really really
very
bad because
we are growing more trees during
every year but the people is still in
cutting
so that's why we need help each big
festival independent days christmas days
and the new year's
people because all these are dancing at
home like this like he said all is a
cutting prophet because missing no
people no patrol
poverty is driving up poaching and even
eating their unique wildlife as people
struggle in the face of unusually
extreme weather
this fat-tailed dwarf lemur which looks
in a very sorry state was rescued by the
guides when it became sick after being
held as a pet
the only primate known to hibernate
kristen and his daughter decide they
have to release the lima back into the
wild how do you feel about saying
goodbye to him now
sad little bitty
front little bit because bikini and you
started looking at me oh you
it
touched my heart
but now it's got the chance of survival
so much of madagascar's natural
treasures are being robbed of that
alex crawford sky news madagascar